[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
good morning guys i'm back with another
vlog today i have so much to do today
because i have two weeks left until the
final exam of my third year of medical
school so i thought we could manifest a
productive day together which is why i'm
bringing along for this one so i've just
made my breakfast now we're gonna take
it upstairs and get as much as work done
as possible today and be productive
together
[Music]
now i'm going through some orthopedics
questions on past med because i just had
my orthopedics rotation last week so
whilst all the information is fresh on
my mind i want to focus on that and
consolidate on that i've got around 147
questions left on orthopedics so after i
finish that i want to focus on
rheumatology and go through all my anki
flash cards on rheumatology then do a
hundred rheumatology questions on past
med just to consolidate on that flash
card knowledge so if i'm done with both
rheumatology and orthopedics today i
would be done with a musculoskeletal
topic so i want to finish
musculoskeletal today so i can move on
to general surgery starting from
tomorrow because i've got my general
surgery rotation starting from tomorrow
so i'd like to focus on the questions of
rotation that i'm in so i'm hoping to do
that today
so
[Music]
i just finished more than half of the
orthopedics questions which i'm very
happy about because it comes up all the
time in the exams and it's a very dry
topic it's all about memorizing bones
and joints and muscles and all the
diseases that's how i'm involved with
those so now i'm going to move my body a
little bit do a quick exercise then i'm
going to go to the kitchen to make some
lunch which i'm going to have for dinner
as well
[Applause]
[Music]
now the afternoon low is really kicking
in but i know that there's only two
weeks left until the end of this
academic year so this is the last push
and we can do this let's get this done
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's about 9 p.m right now so i'm just
going to read my book which is called
the beautiful world where are you the
perspectives of the characters in this
book are very interesting so i'm excited
about that but at the moment i can feel
a tickle of stress coming to me i just
need to do my best and focus for the
next two weeks it'll all be okay in the
end this is just like the final push but
i've been very productive today and if
you need any motivation i'm sending all
that productivity to you i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you